live from the Kodak Theatre at Hollywood
and Highland in Los Angeles California
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences welcomes you to the 79th annual
Academy Awards
you were nominated for Lawrence of
Arabia I walls now why didn't you win
for that somebody else did whoops excuse
me yes yes t doesn't make a real good
movie I'll make a deal bad movie are we
already rolling yes I'm on camera I
almost started to cry in dailies can
just get that energy of the whole house
raucous sound editing sound effects
sound mixing can you hear me
it's always about the sink uh Best
Supporting Actor this is me jumping
around on Oscar morning he said come on
out I was ready to leave and of course
my wife wanted me to stick around and
finish the honeymoon always better the
second time around every time you go to
a movie is a blind date we're not ready
for picture director things like that
that's picture as I reckon the
screenplay to Best Supporting Actress
less editing score Oscar - Manny maybe
don't you think my third nomination six
so you have failed to win an Oscar eight
times no I failed seven but this will be
my eighth I've been nominated 19 times
and I have yet to win eight no wins
zilch losing builds character winning is
easy anybody could win I'm surprised
they let me in at all I'm gonna give you
a rough estimate four or five something
like that
something like that killed as in
murdered or just natural death
it's reality it doesn't even exist it's
all just pixels I believe in hope but I
don't believe in a hope that is a
hula-hula hope because you cannot have
this fear without hope Sam Foley did
this before dividends reports about how
am I gonna ventilate as soon as he heard
the dog he got right up so you played
sound effects for your dog no no no he
was watching the DVD you see a head
rolled down the stairs low that was a
head yeah best original surgeon
screenplay screenplay I'm here for the
Queen okay I can't believe I just I'm
here for the Queen I'm here for the
Queen sorry it's just a surreal thing
for an Englishman to say restrained
polite decent any sexual thought about
the Queen as at reasonable thought let's
be quite clear about off with your head
best art direction we're stepping
through a mirror what does that mean
it's a leap of faith how am I gonna make
her into a Wallflower you like my dress
if you don't wear dresses like this
great what's wrong with Best Original
Song I was able to rhyme Inconvenient
Truth with youth music isn't cheating
except sometimes I'm pretty excited
about being nominated
oh yes excited yes kind of confused too
you're funny doing that really I can't
do it justice and I woke up Tuesday
morning hi documentary short short film
shirts are wonderful to be great if
we're a feature it's been fabulous
it has ups and downs I didn't cut that
see I can tell you that you see I'm
going to thank Kerry Gill Prai for
helping me with my hair
thank you mom thanks mom I thinks mom
bought wouldn't you think your mom
thanks mom thanks me my in-laws and I'm
getting real trouble if I didn't have my
mother to that guilt
exactly I've never thanked my parents
for anything
Buckminster Fuller stand package Wow I'd
like to thank me but I wouldn't dare I
cried when I remember this moment
it's a good life to be allowed to write
songs and to spread some hope and some
joy and some humor around it's not so
bad pretty lucky ladies and gentlemen
here they are the nominees for this
year's Academy Awards
a record 177 artists and craftsmen at
the top of their game have gathered in
the Kodak tonight from around the world
means men and women represent the best
of the best and many have already won
numerous awards for their incredible
work this year but tonight is the big
one
the one they've been waiting for the
gold-standard
it's the Oscars
and now here's your host for the 79th
annual Academy Awards Ellen DeGeneres
thank you so much oh boy what a night so
here we go this is very exciting and as
you saw just now in that film by Academy
Award winning director Errol Morris
tonight we're celebrating the nominees
as opposed to all the other years when
we pretty much just celebrated the
winners